okay
i never played this guy do do kessner or
something
rated 2400 from the us
okay he's playing some
rare bishop knight
97 king's indian
i haven't castled yet so maybe i can go
for h4
idea of h5
yeah he prevented this
okay of course um i don't want to castle
short anymore
yeah of course this is possible and
from a strategic point if you even
desirable to exchange this bishop
still i have much more space
and we'll go for f4
if he takes now i recapture with the
pawn of course
and then h5 is a potential weakness
and i have ideas like rook to f1 and 94
using the four square
it's not entirely clear this position
but
oh interesting
he's um
playing for for this pin here
i take here would take with the bishop
i cannot capture here because he
recaptures with the knight
interesting tactical idea
still this is all very hard for me to
believe
okay let's say i take here should takes
i could also go just rook f1
protecting f5 okay
cannot think all day even if the
opponent is playing complete crap which
i think um
this is basically is um then you should
display a little bit quicker
it doesn't help much at the end if you
over overstep the time
yeah it's got this this really strange
pawn on e3
okay cannot really take on f5 or knight
f6 um
coming up
of course i i want to capture e3
but how do i capture it maybe
trying to to get it with the queen
i thought this was just good for me
maybe i'm overlooking something but
hard to believe e3 hanging h5 hanging
i think queen is seven or maybe it says
trick
knight e5 no i can just take f6
if he goes queen e7 i capture h5
and then he's um he must already
gives some material i think
maybe he needs to set the exchange then
it's very likely
but where else should he go he needs to
go to e7 to protect this pawn
okay
check
just draw that one keep it simple
okay let's see queen
or rook g5 everything's good here
basically
um
i could have taken on f8
if it takes with a rook rook e5
yeah but it's still still working
black resigned yeah i was i overlooked
it the first time
that's the second time of course um
he could he could then recapture with
the queen which is of course looking
looking somewhat stupid but maybe not
losing instantly
yeah this was just just not playable
what he did here
this is um i think better for white but
you can still um try to
put up a solid defense but uh
i don't know this this looks i don't
know unplayable i think
yeah computer also gives me a large
advantage
yeah yeah this was just
to weakening all around
okay next one